foreign
I know a thing or two about this
Courtney and my therapist loves it
[Music]
what's up this is John with the Dr John
deloney show
greatest mental health and emotional
health and marriage relationship show
ever
so says my mom actually my mom doesn't
even think that I think she liked
Frasier Crane better than me but I say
it and um I'm on the internet so it has
to be true right hey um if you want to
be on the show we talk to real people
who are going through real challenges
and we will get to the bottom of it and
figure it out if you want to be on the
show give me a call
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask ask and it's here
it's here you don't have to hear me
begging you to buy this in pre-sale
anymore building a non-anxious life my
brand new book is out and it's
everywhere it's on all the shops and
sites and stores if you want to help me
out the most um where we get the biggest
cut of it you can go to John deloney.com
but if you're an Amazon person or a
Barnes Noble person or a Target whatever
it is it is out in the world go pick up
a copy building a non-anxious life I
promise you it's going to transform the
way you and your loved ones and your
kids and your family lives and that's
the goal here we're going to change our
lives and Kelly is back
um high as a kite yay for cold medicine
dude so you had Cove at six is that
right oh I had a head cold
every time anyone gets a sniffle you
think it's covid
I know beneath because it is I think
you've been because it is
I had a head cold really nasty head cold
for a few days but I'm back
you're cold you're cold spent some time
up there and they're like I think it's
time for us to head out this isn't a
good place for us good job I love a good
boss who's dymatapped out of her mind no
like uh DayQuil DayQuil day man a little
bit of the night
but let me some Dayquil and some
friendship and karate and if that's a
deep cut and if you know what that's
from shoot me a DM and I'll send you
something because that's awesome let's
go out to San Francisco California and
talk to Jacob what's up Jacob
hey John thank you so much for taking my
call of course what's up man
yeah um I guess I'll get right into it
sir
last few years I've been struggling with
um porn addiction
tell me about it man yeah
so um hold on one second is that the
first time you've said that out loud
I think so yeah yeah thank you for
sharing that man
of course did that feel weird and
surreal to say that out loud
well I've read I've written it down on
the paper a lot but
um yeah that's the first time I set it
up yeah well I'm I'm grateful that you
um trusted me enough to
to say that appreciate that so tell me
tell me about the the origin story here
man yeah uh
um I guess I'll walk you through the
like how I got to this point and how it
like the reason why I want the call and
perfect yeah
so earlier this year I started reading
your book
um on your past change your future
and I got to about halfway
and one of the questions to ask is uh
what are a few things that you did
either growing up in the recent past the
hot tube or that violate the person that
you want
and for me this is one of those things
how did you get started
started as in like
I mean if you go back and you you pull
the thread on your your personal story
your personal history when's the first
time you were exposed to this that you
knew oh I I want to see that again
when I was 12. okay and it started off
as
um
just like regular pornography and then
it slowly got worse and worse throughout
throughout the years
um
I'd say it was worse when I was like 15
or 16. and I'm still trying to like get
over the hunt but
um it's worse I was engaging in
um video chat pornography with other
women online okay
even as a as a 15 and 16 year old
yes wow
so much for the safeguards they talk
they're so proud of
yeah that it's just adults talking to
adults yeah that's tough man that is
um blowing out the hedonic sensor in
your brain man that's a lot of a lot of
Freewheel and cheap dopamine circling up
in that system and that is
really really hard to just control all
delete and walk away from so what has
happened recently that that you reached
out usually people something has
happened
yeah what happened so uh recently I'm
starting out the first semester of
college
and oh so you're 18 right now
yeah this is like my second week oh wow
okay
how's the first week going
oh man it's so much fun I I really like
it um
yeah
doing great okay so this is week week
you're into week two
what happened
well I think right now would be a good
time to really
um you know be aggressive and try and
get some work done on this and move
forward
let us be aggressive look like for you
that looks like
making progress
um putting in the hard work to end this
addiction okay
I agree with the be aggressive part of
what you said
that is counter to make progress
okay we're going to make progress on the
the cheap dopamine we're gonna make
progress on channeling some of this
angst and loneliness and shame into
productive behaviors okay
but we are going to be aggressive about
the
external presenting problem as is the
way we say it in the nerd World okay
okay what does that mean that means if
you're gonna get serious about this you
have to go scorched Earth and here's why
it's everywhere
and so when you like
when somebody is struggling with alcohol
when they have deemed themselves an
alcoholic
they cannot have a beer
especially at the beginning they can't
go into a bar at the beginning they
can't go to a friend's house where
they're serving alcohol at the beginning
many of them can get there over time but
at the beginning it is scorched Earth
what does scorched earth mean for you
that might mean getting rid of your
phone
or sharing apps with your parents
that might mean get rid of your laptop
which makes College almost impossible
and you have to go to the school library
to type on something or you have to
borrow a laptop from the school and what
I'm saying sounds insane and people are
going to be driving listening to this
and roll their eyes
but I've sat with too many young people
in your situation dude in college in my
dean of students offices at colleges
across the country and you are haunted
aren't you
I think so yeah
fair enough Fair
absolutely fair so
do your parents have any idea that
you're struggling so much or that you've
been
engaging in what I I mean
live sex via Zoom essentially since you
were 15 years old 14 years old
well I think they they
knew at some point but I don't think
they knew just how bad it was
were they thinking like with a Playboy
mindset
like a lot of parents a lot of parents
hear pornography and they think of the
Playboys that their friend's dad had
under the bed or their dad headed to the
bed
they don't have a psychology for oh no
my son is talking to somebody in another
country and she will do anything he asks
her to and talk back to him the whole
time
right that is not in most parents
psychology and that you can do that from
your freaking cell phone
yeah or your laptop in your bedroom
and you're saying I'm playing Call of
Duty mom and you're literally talking to
a 24 year old woman in another country
that is an insanity and a Madness that
most parents don't understand is
happening
Fair
okay
so two words that are really important
to me when I hit when I'm sitting with
somebody who is struggling with any sort
of a form of addiction and my guess is
you've you've tried to not do this on
your own right like you've said I'm not
doing this anymore and you shut the
laptop and you delete all the apps and
you've slowly found your way back is
that fair
yeah that's that's definitely been the
situation on and off over the last few
years okay so the two words that always
guide my conversations with folks is
awareness and curiosity so I'll just ask
you
what are the times if you look back and
you could say oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
one of the times you have re-downloaded
the apps
anytime I've found like a loophole or
some way to access
um
the addiction
so like I'll give an example so like
last week I had
um an old Chromebook that I forgot I had
and I guess I was so desperate that I
ended up using it
um and then immediately after I I threw
it away
well I do agree with you that most
Chromebooks should end up in the trash
like we we are in alignment there
um
man
so when somebody says I'm struggling
with pornography I've got a porn
addiction
um
that's a spectrum
but
just you and me being honest you're way
over your head aren't you
I'm actually not quite sure um what that
means
that means you found your ways into some
dark areas of the world through that
through that computer haven't you
yeah
and you've seen some gnarly stuff
haven't you
yeah yeah
foreign
have you reached out to a professional
at this point
um I have not okay I need you to hear me
super clear okay you're on a trajectory
a rocket ship to jail
you are particularly on a rocket ship to
get yourself kicked out of college
okay
okay I'm telling you that because I've
investigated one step of where you are
right now at the University level on
multiple occasions
okay
yeah
am I right
um yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna trust for
you sir okay no you're on a dangerous
path as I'm telling you
and if you haven't already you will be
approached for things
that because here's what here when you
say you get desperate
it's that pressure it builds and it
builds and it builds and it builds and
you will do anything like find an old
computer and you will eventually end up
on a school laptop or your neighbor's
laptop or you will find yourself
responding to a chat like hey if you
think that was cool I got something for
you or some call girl on the computer
who says
if you thought that was awesome
click this link or call this number
because they'll up the ante and now you
are way over your head
and so what what I'm telling you right
now is and it it doesn't happen it
happens so benign and so next step that
suddenly people go oh my because I'm
here
I have a I have a computer full of child
pornography I have a computer full of
um really graphic
um like disturbing pornography if you're
not already there in either of those
situations
so here's I'm telling you step one
when we get off this call I want you to
make an appointment with a male
counselor at your College Counseling
Center today right now
got it okay I want you to go be as open
with that person as you are with me
and I want you to say the following
words
I have an addiction to pornography
but it is not just images and it's not
just movies I have for the last three or
four years been in regular contact with
live models and actors who will do what
I say on screen
you have to start there with that level
of honesty with your with your counselor
okay
okay that's step one
step two you need to see if you have a
local essay I think it's sexaholics
Anonymous I don't know the exact
verbiage there in your hometown where
you happen to be I promise you do and I
promise you will not be the only college
kid in that meeting
but the whole you have to get into a
place where you can say these things out
loud and it's important to see where
this all can head and it will also be
important to see a group of men who are
past you who are older than you wiser
than you who have
completely taken ownership back of their
life
okay
so that's two things that's two sources
of accountability here's the intentional
stuff right in front of you I want you
to write this down and I want you to put
this on your mirror I want you to put
this by your bed I want you to put this
everywhere that you're going to see
something
e y d earn your dopamine
no more hacks no more
um sideways attempts
if you want intimacy sexual intimacy
connection I have to go on a date I have
to earn my dopamine I gotta ask somebody
out and work and risk getting um dumped
if I want to lose weight I'm not just
going to take a bunch of speed and a
bunch of
um whatever pills I'm gonna go to the
gym
if I'm gonna do good on a test I'm not
going to cheat my way to that dopamine
I'm going to study really hard
earn your dopamine is it's my buddy
Michael Easter calls it the two percent
rule it is a intentional like way of
doing life I'm gonna take the harder
path because the harder path I take the
more extraordinary the result is on the
other end of this thing
okay but this is you this is gonna be a
complete reframe what does that look
like in real life always take the stairs
always
even when you have to make two trips
avoid the elevator avoid the escalator
always tip more than you think is
appropriate always ask somebody if you
can carry their bag
and that's probably not the world you've
lived in for a long time but this is a
complete shift
okay
the second thing is is you're gonna have
to get really scorched Earth about your
products I mean your your digital access
in your house
you can't control yourself at this
moment in time you can't
so you have to put so many hurdles in
front of you
I'll go as far to say if you need to
step away from college for a semester
and have no access to a computer do that
I'll go as far to say get rid of your
your smartphone and get a flip phone
and act all cool about it like I'm just
a hip trendy cool guy with the flip
phone whatever you have to do
I just have had this conversation more
times than I can count you are over your
head you're over your head you're over
your head
and I'll give you a quote from the great
brene Brown shame eats secrets for
breakfast
shame gathers its strength and power
from secrets that's why
essay meetings and a counselor they're
going to be so crucial because I'm
saying these things out loud shame will
have no power over me anymore when you
dispel shame now you can actually get to
the issues that drive you to some of
this stuff some of that impulse Behavior
then you're going to start becoming
aware oh every time I get in a fight
with my mom or every time I feel lonely
I just start to reach for the computer
ah okay I'm going to become more aware
and more why I keep reaching for the
computer ah okay it's because I'm tired
because I haven't eaten well it's
because of Any number of things
and then when you get that shred of
awareness
as the great Dr Judd Brewer says that's
when that's when Behavior change can
happen
that's it
that's gonna take a minute
and what I don't want you to do is get
yourself over your head even more get
yourself arrested get continue this this
path of
hurting the women on the other end of
this stuff
and if you want to go to do a deep dive
into
the women on the if especially those in
other countries on the other end of
these webcam things it's Madness now I
know that only fans is a whole other
conversation we can have but
nobody wins man
I will say this I'm really proud of you
for calling Jacob
really proud of you from Colin
I think you got to college and saw all
these incredible friends you're gonna
make and and started seeing people that
I think I want to be like this
and you knew you had this looming
terrifying secret in the closet and I'm
proud of you for opening the closet door
and saying no more
it'll be a tough tough road pornography
is everywhere and every phone every
computer everywhere
so you're gonna be swimming Upstream my
brother
but I promise you can do it we'll be
right back
this episode is sponsored by Better
Health hey folks deloni here sometimes
we know what's good for us but it feels
like we just can't make ourselves do it
like our brain's getting in its own way
and that happens to me a lot and I'm
pretty sure it happens to you I know I
should play a game with my kids instead
of practicing my guitar all night but
sometimes my brain tells me that hey
maybe that metal band's gonna call after
all you got to get your practice in
therapy helps me figure out what's
holding me back from doing what I know I
should do and it can help you too so
your brain can begin to work with you
not against you sometimes it's just as
simple as talking things through and
learning how to intentionally Place
guard rails between yourself and
negative behaviors we call them
boundaries so if you're thinking of
starting therapy give better help a try
better help is flexible because it's
totally online so it can fit your
schedule just fill out a brief question
here to get matched with the licensed
therapist you can switch therapists at
any time for no extra charge make your
brain your friend with better help visit
betterhelp.com deloney today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right let's go out to the Oklahoma
City and talk to Courtney what's up
Courtney
hello hello
what's up
I almost sick kids that sounds par for
the course these days fan sounds to be
the way it is right now they are lucky
to have you what's up
calling because I had a question for you
basically how do I prepare my kids for
the dangers of the world without without
scaring them too much basically
um well where does the question come
from
so my whole family is in law enforcement
I grew up with my dad yes sweet yeah
yeah
I know a thing or two about this
Courtney and my therapist loves it
so my dad's a police officer my brother
decided to get the family gig and then I
married my high school sweetheart and he
went through the highway patrol Academy
while I when we've been married for 12
years and he's been a highway patrolman
my whole our whole marriage as well so
it's just it's in the blood but what do
you do for a living
I'm interested oh my gosh really
yeah so your kids have a cop and a um
nurse practitioner as parents yeah
have you ever traumatized them over here
have you rubber root like like rubber
padded the house yet
um
there's always that Mom and it's
Courtney
um so do you know my background at all
yes I listen to you every chance I get
okay all right so
talk to you you've probably you've
probably heard me talk about this but my
old man was a homicide detective and it
was a SWAT hostage negotiator so same
thing right
and he would because he loved me no
mistake about it because he loved me
he would go to work and on the family
desk he would put Polaroids because we'd
have digital cameras back then of guys
getting out of jail
that he had helped put away and he would
say hey these guys may get out come
looking for me if they knock on the door
don't answer
yeah and I remember I remember growing
up being like okay and so every time
somebody ring the doorbell I was like
this is it right this is the one so in
his attempt to love me and by the way
uh well we'll get to that in a second
his attempt to love me it created quite
the nervous system right yeah and I I
still to this day cannot enter a
restaurant without sitting with my back
against the wall
so weird I ca I can't I can't do it like
if I don't sit that way I just feel like
I am sitting on an exit or whatever oh
dude hey I didn't know that everybody
didn't walk in and look at all the exits
when they walk into any room anywhere
nope that's not normal I didn't know
that until I saw my first counselor and
she's like you're insane right
um and
so I I wanna and I did research on the
mental health of medical practitioners
and so y'all are just a barrel of
monkeys too right yeah for fun just stop
talk is real great
yes it is it's actually you have to have
that and actually your sense of humor
gets so so
dark because you have to right you have
to I get that and that's fantastic
the challenge is um here's the way I
describe it about about my dad
it shifted his entire bell curve of the
world and here's what I mean by that you
and me Courtney we're in Oklahoma City
we're walking down a dark alley and
we're heading to an opera together
because you're into Opera that's super
weird I wanted to go to the Pantera Show
but no Courtney had to go to Opera so
we're going down the down the alley to
go to Opera and another person is
walking towards us
999 times out of a thousand they just
walk by us
998 999th time they're like hey I got
two front row seats to the operating I
want them and we're like yeah that would
be great
and then the thousands time
they pull out a hatchet and chop me and
you up in little pieces right yeah my
dad's job a hundred percent of his life
was that thing that never happens to
anybody
that's correct and so I got a ticket the
other day because I was driving way too
fast
and the guy pulled me over I smiled he
caught me I was breaking the law I
handed him my stuff I was like well done
man and he looked at me kind of weird
and I go I was going way too fast I know
that you know that and he smiled went
back wrote me a ticket and I was on my
way and that's the majority of the
interactions
but your husband has seen all the
training videos and he's been involved
in a few and he's his shop talk is that
one time it happened to that guy and
that one time happened to that guy and
suddenly it's happening to all of us
right yeah
how old are your kids
eight five and almost two oh geez Louise
on a stick okay
so
I'm gonna tell you how it's happened how
I've tried to uh
the way I'm trying to do it right now
okay and you can just take this for what
this is
um two big phrases
well actually one phrase there's the
share don't scare have you heard that
statement
yeah okay
I do think that if you have a police
officer as a dad this is a highway
patrolman and a nurse practitioner is a
mom you get a really unique beautiful
powerful insight into how the world
works
and things that could happen and I think
that's actually really amazing and it
would be a tragedy to hide that from
your kids
the other side of that is there is hey
uh
any number of 12 guys who are getting
out of jail might murder you hashtag
just saying there's that or
there is hey we don't answer the door
when Mom and Dad are gone we just don't
do that
daddy works with really scary people Mom
helps people
um who have had really scary things
happen to them we just don't open the
door for people period
and there's a big difference there
here's another example with my 13 year
old son I talk about this all the time
we go to Waffle House but I don't talk
about enough and I probably should
is we have a 9-1-1 rule me and my wife
me and my kids that they know
if I say
hey this is 9-1-1 walk out that door
right now there's no questions there's
no talking there's no anything they head
out that door
and I had that um recently somebody came
in and they were messed out of their
minds
and it was it was enough that I went oh
this ends badly for everybody in this
tiny little restaurant
and I looked at my son and said this is
a 9-1-1 moment
if I if I tell you to go into the
kitchen and walk out that back door
don't ask any questions you want to cut
that back door and he said yes sir
and I thought we had a moment and I said
this is 9-1-1 head out the front door go
and he I mean dude his credit he got up
and started heading out the door and as
he headed out the door of course the guy
got up to go to kind of cut us off a
little bit and that allowed me to
intervene and I gently intervened and he
didn't have the money to pay for his
food and I paid for his food and I said
hey it happens to all of us I think it's
time for us to go and it ended very
peacefully
yeah and then I was able to debrief that
but that what I had in place was not hey
those guys at those restaurants are
gonna kill you so that my son walks in
and scans every restaurant
and also I put him in a position and
kind of uh I mean probably not the best
place to take your kid right and I took
him there because I feel comfortable I
feel safe and I've got a plan with him
and then we debriefed and that was the
important part on the back end hey you
saw this thing uh I want you to know
like here's why I did what I did here's
what I would have done if this had
gotten sideways and you I'm so proud of
you because the smartest thing you could
do is take yourself out of the situation
not try to be John Wick right you see
what I'm saying like it's it's coming up
with a plan on the back end and I think
it's okay to say they're scary people
if something happened yeah I was gonna
say if something happened that you were
like oh no
well I so I also have had a like a legit
stalker and so like I'm always like lock
the door shut the house like put the
alarm on and I think that I've put the
fear of that situation even though he's
not around right now
um on to my kids too and so I don't want
them to be fearful like there's the
boogeyman behind us but at the same time
like be safe and the reason I brought
this up was because I hurt my
eight-year-old saying something to my
five-year-old that I was like oh I did
that to you I'm so sorry what was it
um I can't remember the specifics but it
was just like we have to make sure that
the alarm's line we have to make sure
that the doors are locked and we have to
be beside mom all the time at the
restaurant like she was very specific on
like all the rules that I have
and I just don't want her to have that
dampness on the world as the glass is
the dark glasses on that me and my
husband do yes because she's just a kid
but I don't want to minimize that y'all
also have the light too and I think
whenever I work with police officers and
I work with police groups and I work
with medical professionals and Med
students I always want to make sure they
don't miss the light because they see
that too
yeah because you've seen some insane
recoveries
even when somebody has passed away
you've seen families come together in
Waiting rooms that probably still gives
you Goosebumps if you thought about it
right
and your husband has seen people who are
out of their mind on drugs get well and
come by and say hey I just want you know
I'm doing great he's seen that too and
he's pulled people over and probably
kept them from hurting themselves or
killing themselves and so there's light
too it's just that often in these
professions there's so much Darkness we
miss it right
and so that guy at a restaurant come up
to my husband and say thanks for saving
me yes exactly and it's easy to go yeah
I was doing my job
Hey where's the exit right it's easy to
blow that off and it's like no no no
that's equally as valid that's light
and that guy that pulled me over I've
been much more careful
and so he did his job I didn't and now
I'm being more careful he may have saved
countless other people for me being an
idiot driver you see what I'm saying so
there's light there too
what I think is important to let your
kids know is not so much that the world
is out to get you which in a weird way
it is right it is
But Mommy gets nervous about some things
so here's how here's another example
that's kind of unrelated but it is
related I am terrified comically like
insanely pathologically of heights
like a second story I at my neighbor's
house on the second story I don't like
it I don't like looking over the rail I
put myself up against the wall and so
when my kids run up and lean over
because they have no fear of anything
I will grab their shirt and I will look
at them and they'll turn and go Dad and
I'll say hey this is just for your old
man
this is just for me because I'm nuts and
they'll go okay Dad now okay yeah I have
sat with a family after somebody fell
off of something really high
it's not just for me but mostly it's
just for me all right
and so it's both and I think it's coming
up with the plan and letting them know
oh hey the lights I mean the locks and
the uh alarms that's Mom that's just for
me nobody's coming in the house guys
nobody's coming in the house if they do
there's a plan
but nobody's coming in the house guys
this is just for Mom this is just for me
I like whenever dad's gone I like
sleeping with it like with all the stuff
on
and letting them know oh Mom's a little
bit out there but we'll do that for Mom
and they will slowly start to see this
and if you see somebody who's choking in
a restaurant you see somebody who's been
hurt
um the other day Josephine came home and
I was telling something to my wife my
daughter came home
or came up on the porch where we were
talking
and she said dad why do you look like
that in her classic Josephine way and I
said
I had a really hard day I had to talk to
somebody whose kid is very very sick and
it made me sad
that's all I didn't tell him that
somebody that I care about and loves kid
has cancer in its terminal and it's
scary I just said Somebody's got a kid
in the sick and made me very very sad
because I don't think kids are supposed
to get sick like that and she crawled up
in my lap
and so she knows I told her she knows
and also I never once expressed a dad's
out of control and number two
um I let her know like I got emotions
and I get sad too but I don't want her
wearing the emotions of my house and I
think you had that experience with your
kids like hey we gotta lock this thing
up they're starting to absorb the fear
and the fear is becoming theirs not
yours and I think it's important to take
ownership of that fear back
and all police officers all nurses all
doctors everybody I think it's always
going to be attention
between my kids got to know they gotta
know what it's like out there and also
not over
um explaining things before they're
ready to hear them
right and that's a scary place to be but
that's the world we're in
and I'll just end the call with this
thank you thank you and your husband for
pulling over idiots like me who are
driving too fast for helping save
people's lives on the side of the road
for showing up
to the medical profession which has been
just a dumpster fire of the last few
years
um thank you thank you all thank you all
thank y'all thank you and I know you
want to get this one perfect too get
this one perfect too your kids are
resilient and they're going to be tough
and they're going to have their issues
because Dad was a cop and mom was a
medical professional
and also man they won the lottery with
you too it's amazing we'll be right back
what's up friends Dr John deloney here
and I want to let you in on a secret
that most people didn't tell you before
you got married honesty and intimacy
take practice they don't just happen you
gotta put the Reps in in a beautiful
weekend away in Nashville Tennessee is a
great way to do just that so join me in
Rachel Cruz right here at the Ramsey
Event Center for a money and marriage
getaway you'll learn how to have healthy
conversations around money boundaries
and even sex and Intimacy in your
marriage plus we're gonna have an
incredible great time this weekend is
for couples in every season of life and
engaged couples are welcome too but it's
coming up fast October 19th through the
21st it's a three-day Retreat the cost
is 799 bucks but you can take a hundred
dollars off when you use the code deloni
at checkout that's three Incredible Days
for you and your spouse for just 699
bucks go to ramseysolutions.com getaway
today day that's ramseysolutions.com
getaway
all right let's go out to North Carolina
and talk to Melissa what's up Melissa
hey Dr John thank you for taking my call
I love your show
thank you so much I appreciate you
calling what's up
um well so we have a new situation in
our family
um my husband and I have been married
almost 30 years and we have five adult
kids and um
yes yes it's great though
um so
Emily and we're very close
um we're Christian family and
um you know we're kind of always in our
kids ears and you know trying to guide
them and shape them even in their adult
life
so how very helicoptery of you
I'm sure they never go out for chips and
queso to talk about God did mom call you
too that never happened so good okay all
the time it's like you already live here
um so yes you have nailed me perfectly
already so good good all right so what's
up recently none of them have been
married okay I wonder why
was anyone ever good enough for Mama
Melissa
uh well you know I always told my kids
when I was raising them we didn't do the
boyfriend girlfriend thing I always said
to the boys I said you don't need a
girlfriend until you need a wife and to
my girls I said you don't need a
boyfriend until you need a husband
meaning but it's not like do this you
know in you know second grade so and so
like so and so like I just I didn't want
to do that I didn't want to put that on
them and I just kind of wanted to shape
them to really think about their future
spouses and as they got older my husband
I met in youth group we've we've been
joined at the hip since we were 15 and
16. and we're best friends we're very
united front
um and as the kids got older and into
you know teen years and stuff I'd say
you know you guys really need to think
about who what characteristics you want
in your future spouses and you know all
of that see how they act with their
parents see what their parents
relationship is like you know make sure
your spiritual values are similar you
know all this right
well our fourth child who is a boy
joined the Marine Corps when he was uh
just shy of 18 and he just injured his
fifth year of service
and um lucky us were stationed pretty
close he's stationed pretty close to
home
um he met a girl
um online and fell madly in love and
um they eloped
very quickly
um in fact it's kind of a situation like
she again
it's hilarious you're lack of it it's
not but your lack of approval is so
endearing it's so
well he totally total shocked me right
of course right so okay I have to say
this I know this isn't about the call
but I have to just say this out loud is
this is that okay go go
and I hesitate to do this because I
don't want you to hold on to it so can I
just have this opinion and I can get off
the phone you can go that guy's stupid
is that cool
you say what you want to say okay I'm
ready this exact moment is why I think
it's very important for kids to date
because there's not a reference point is
physiologically in their bodies
for love for for that ooey gooey feeling
that overwhelm that tsunami of emotion
and if they are old enough to it's kind
of like I want my kid to roller skate
and I want my kid to ride a bike and I
want my kid to ride shotgun in a golf
cart or a four-wheeler before they ever
get in a car
because if I just wait wait wait wait
wait wait 21 here's your car look I can
do whatever I want to go wherever I want
I can drive wherever it's a lot right so
it's so it is not a common for
it's like a drink in a glass and you
know the ice is at the bottom and said
oh Dimitri Martin joke it's just
fantastic the ice sits at the back back
and then it all just dumps in your face
it's like this right like don't date
don't date don't date I found someone
online she says I love you and it's like
let's get married right now and it's
just this and all of a sudden it's like
no and you've lost it my second favorite
thing is is when you said
he totally shocked me and I want to tell
you the unbridled
passion
of a child can't be held by their
parents
it can't be held and in fact you don't
actually want that
I think you want to protect your kid
from any sort of hurt ever they're going
to have and by doing so you rob them of
all of their Joy too all of that
wildness all that I did it on my own all
of that crazy
and that becomes about you not about
them but that so every kid you have I
hope they shock you that's what kids are
supposed to do because we're not we we
didn't uh they weren't little puppies
that we trained and not pee in the house
right these are wild men and women that
we are releasing into the world with our
love and with our the lessons we taught
them and our values and they're going to
come up with their own oh you see what
I'm saying it's a it's a terrifying
Enterprise and here we are okay so I
just interrupted you just had to get
that out of my system so we're back no
it's good and and I agree and um this
girl is girl number three in his life so
he's only dated two other girls so to
your point I I get it um we can't change
that so here we are right exactly
exactly
um she did not enjoy her home life
um and she's younger she's 18 uh she'll
be 19
um in a couple months so um didn't
didn't really love being at home met
this handsome guy online uh flew to
North Carolina
um I got he brought her over on Sunday
and then I I think they were married by
Tuesday right
in person so very Whirlwind yeah right
so he shows up on Wednesday the next day
with a wedding ring on and I'm like hey
what's that I ordered a Mexican
restaurant eating chips and queso and I
was like dude what's that and he's like
oh
I'm Dad we went to the courthouse
yesterday and we got married and I was
like what I I would have paid money to
have been at that table just to watch
that happen I jumped up
oh good for you hey I'm
I'm huge good for you good for you
I I I mean look that's awesome yes
helicopter mom totally but but also
you're great I told her while I was oh
sorry what I told her while I was
hugging her is I said you know since
before he was born
I have prayed for his future spouse
and I'm so glad he found you
was I scared to death I absolutely was
scared to death but that is the truth
and that's my heart and here's the cool
thing awesome I'm glad you didn't lean
into your ear and Whisper while you're
hugging her I'm gonna kill you
that's what Kelly would have done so
good for you good for you no no no no
and here's the
only known her for a couple months now
um but she's awesome okay like she's
awesome so what's the catch what's the
catch there's a catch here here's the
yeah here's the catch here's where I
need some help
um her
as you can imagine her relationship with
her mom and dad is not great
um she did not tell them that they were
married until just a few weeks ago
um her parents have basically said
um don't come back home until you're
divorced they want nothing to do with my
son they want nothing to do with our
family they have actually since um moved
to the state so they're fairly close
um they're not in the same city but
they're fairly close
um and here's here's where I need some
advice
I have
told her that I would
I'm very close with my mom and I have
said family is very important and I want
you to be able to reconcile with your
mom and dad
um
I'm not trying to you know push but
whenever she would come to me to talk
about them I would just say you know I'm
sorry you're going through this I really
hope that one day you guys can reconcile
because I think you want your mom and
dad
in in your life like I think parents
play a key part
um they do but I'd be very careful about
saying that and here's why
there may be
highways of abuse that you don't know
about
and when some when when people tell
somebody who's been in an abusive
situation or an ugly situation often
people who've experienced that
especially 18 or 19 year olds they let
that stuff out centimeter by centimeter
and it starts with yeah I didn't want to
be at home home was really rough I
didn't like it there that is them slowly
testing the waters
is this okay to talk is this a safe
place
and when people are like man you really
need to go back to your family you're
going to miss them they start to feel
insane
right and so I think your heart is
beautiful you had a great relationship
with your mom and that was super
important to you sometimes the greatest
relationship with between a mom and a
daughter is a severed one
because Mom was brutal to me
and it doesn't surprise me that she
comes to you somebody who is super smart
super fun who loves her husband as much
as she does if not way more
and who is I mean you you are you sound
so grounded and rooted in who you are
right and so
um
for her somebody who might have come
from a troubled home and again I'm
projecting into her world her parents
might have just wanted to have a curfew
at 18 and she's like I'm getting married
and so who knows right but if I may yeah
if I can inject here she has said
um she feels that
um she has an older brother who's in
therapy that has
this is just word of mouth but brother
has said that
um the therapist has told him that the
parents are emotionally abusive and
narcissistic and so when I had told her
boy I hope that one day you can
reconcile with healthy boundaries sure
you know that's right that's right but
but that that reconciliation at this
point will never be hers to own
because her mom and dad who walked away
from her
she didn't run away from them she got
married as an adult a very very young
adult yeah they looked at her and said
we are breaking up with you
and so I think that I hope y'all can
reconcile with boundaries someday is I
hope your mom sees what an amazing young
woman you are
oh that's good okay one day okay the
woman I'm seeing standing before me
right now who makes my son light up like
a Christmas tree I hope one day your mom
sees how amazing you are because I see
it
that's different than okay I hope y'all
can reconcile someday because every kid
goes through a season and at last well
into adulthood for folks especially in
abusive situations
of asking of their you've heard this it
sounds so woo and cheesy but it's not
that little nine-year-old kid inside of
you going what was so bad about me
are you so mean to me or why did you
care more about your phone or care more
about your job what was so wild in your
life that
you hit me all the time like whatever
the thing is right and so
um
I don't ever want her to own that her
parents looked at her and they said
because of your choice we abandon you
until you make different choice and that
could be marriage that could be
um that could be job that could be
because she's doing drugs that could be
any number of reasons but Mom and Dad
are the ones that walked out
and they give her a boundary and the
boundary is you will divorce that
military guy
and she's not gonna do that
they have done what I think is an
unforgivable sin for parents and that is
force their child to choose them or
their spouse
that's a that's a brutal decision and
what you did like I hope all the parents
listening what you did in that
restaurant
the number of times I've met with a
parent who has said especially I was
working in the universities
whatever conversation my kid came home
and said ex my kid came home and said
well my kid came home and said they've
been struggling with this they've
they said I would do anything to have
that moment back because I didn't handle
it right
and you did Melissa that's amazing the
fact that you got up in your first move
was a hug even though inside your your
heart had melted and was leaking out
your feet that that's amazing and by the
way when your kids get older
you can tell him that because you get a
moment too here's what here's like so
all all
Kumbaya side here's the big picture you
had a very clear picture of what your uh
like later adult years were going to
look like
and it was going to be your sons would
marry beautiful girls who would look
like X or Y and your daughters would
marry beautiful boys who looked like X
and Y and all of y'all's family would
vacation together and y'all would hang
out it was gonna be and that wasn't your
picture to paint
and so there's going to be a true grief
that you have because you have been a
parent who's tried to control every
variable since they were zero
and now you turn these amazing men onto
the world one of whom is already
dedicated a half a half a decade to
service
of other people
and he's a wildcat man he's out there
and so you're gonna have to grieve that
picture because his uh her parents don't
want anything to do with you and you
can't fix that because you didn't do
anything wrong
okay and that's the picture I think that
I'm grieving like I love her for him and
I love their story and I think the
longer their marriage lasts the cooler
their story is going to become
absolutely right it's like a Nicholas
Stark's romance novel developing and or
one of Kelly's murder podcasts it could
go either way it could go either way I'm
just kidding I'm telling you can't eat
it or until I play but you're right this
could be a beautiful story but it's
there it's not yours yeah but you're
right because my husband and I met at a
Baptist Church and his parents are
friends with my parents and
we don't vacation together but we could
and so
the second part of my question was not
just how like should I stop suggesting
that she reconciled like what what
should be my words to her which thank
you that's perfect I love that but the
second part was I haven't made contact
or tried to make contact with her mom
and dad I actually did meet her dad he
showed up at our house
um
um to check on her which
I I don't know I kind of I gave him
props for that how was that meeting
um you know it
it was okay a little awkward
um my husband is law enforcement so you
know we have a police cruiser in the car
and he showed up and knocked on the door
and he said he was very nervous but this
was shortly after she had come down here
um and they just wanted to lay eyes on
her because she had really put just a
hard stop she she wasn't responding
um to text or calls or anything and one
day if my daughter Josephine listens to
this if she ran off and got on a plane
and married somebody at 18
I can guarantee you I would be on that
front porch the following day
of course right so good for that guy
yeah good for him and and I and I told
her I said you know I give him props for
coming I'm sure that you know but he
just wants to make sure you're okay and
I get that and
um so you know it was we weren't hugging
when he showed up but I mean we were all
very cordial he he did shake hands with
my son at this point he didn't know that
they were married and she didn't want to
tell him so it was just some layers of
awkwardness but um I would run it
through her I would run through her and
say I am feeling this this this sense
inside of my mom heart that I want to
reach out to your parents
let them know that you're safe and
you're doing amazing and if they ever
want to connect we'd love to connect
with them
um and she might tell you please please
do not do that
and if at least in this season I would
honor that okay
um all right so or she might say you can
do whatever you want but I I would again
what you're giving her is something she
may have never had which is a an older
adult who trusts her
and that you like you are you are in a
weird way practicing your new
relationship with her
and that is you going first saying I
don't trust you here's what I think is
the right thing to do I think married
parents like at least need to wave and
say hi to each other and shake hands
um so I'm feeling this mom seems to do
that I want to just sit down with you I
also think it would be a beautiful thing
as much as possible this is pie in the
sky but if y'all live in the same
Community it would be awesome if just
you and her once a month set up a
breakfast together
kid she's a kid right
um so I guess I didn't tell you right
now they are living at my home until he
gets space housing set up yeah so I have
lots of access and um it's but don't
have too much access oh actually you
know what yeah as much as you want
because they're in your house that's
what they get for getting married and
then moving into their mom's house and
it's temporary they don't plan on being
here long base housing takes a while to
get sure
um get set up but um things are going
well but like they have their own space
and so you know we might come together
you know I I get to see her every day
you know she's found a job already I
mean she's really doing amazing so I I
but thank you but you're gonna you are
gonna be moved by the run-ins what I
call accidental Community you're going
to be moved by the hallway interactions
in the early morning at the coffee pot
interactions
with that little girl's desperate for
she's not a little girl she's 18 but
she's a little girl with that young
woman is desperate for
is another adult to sit across a
breakfast room table and say tell me
tell me about it
yeah a focused and because what you're
giving her right now is Twitter bites
and what she needs is a story she needs
a book
and I don't think she's ever had that
[Music]
with me and um she's so desperate for
for Love from her mom
yeah that isn't there it was it was so
funny
um shortly after they got married Maybe
three four weeks after they had gotten
married and and were here my husband and
I had um it wasn't really an argument
but you know we had like the house was
kind of a mess we had just gotten back
from a trip and there was stuff
everywhere and I was like look dude
there
this his his father had given him a
bunch of like football stuff like we're
big Michigan football fans and I was
like there's stuff in like eight oh go
Blue there's something like eight rooms
of the house I work from home I was like
look dude I have got to have help like
we need to get this stuff I I need to
put somewhere and and he was like I
don't know why you're getting upset with
me and I was like dude I'm not upset I'm
just saying I need help we need to you
know contain this and put it somewhere
because I got to get back to work
tomorrow and there's normal stuff you
know the dogs and I was like this is
just crazy and my older daughter was
here and and and my husband has said I
just don't know why you're yelling at me
and I think Katie am I yelling I don't
feel like I'm yelling and Katie says
well Mom you know how when you ask Dad
why is he yelling and we know that dad's
kind of annoyed and he's not really
yelling but we get where you're coming
from she's like yeah you're doing that
and I was like oh okay all right family
I'm sorry I'm not trying to raise my
voice I'm not trying to yell I just need
everyone to help me get the stuff put up
paint uh my daughter-in-law like looked
up and she said wait someone's yelling
who's fighting like what what's going on
because she said at home yes things are
flying through the air and profanity is
flying and divorce is being threatened
and
um you know just all sorts of so let me
say this my wife said this the other day
and it was instructive and I'll leave
you with this
um she had a really stressful couple of
days doing some stuff and she's in the
middle of a huge she's finishing up her
book and she's she's editing it's just a
wild season for her and I was sitting on
the couch which is something I hardly
ever do I just plug down the couch and
she said hey
I'm gonna turn a show on because I need
to borrow some of your nervous system
for a while
because I was super chill
and I laughed and said you got it and
she leaned way I mean burrowed in like a
puppy does and
after the show was over like 45 minutes
or how long the show she's like ah
thanks
and I want you to keep that in your mind
that this little girl this this like you
call a little girl she's a 18 19 20 year
old woman
um this woman needs to borrow your
nervous system for a while
she needs a new picture speaking of new
pictures of what a functioning house
looks like
of what a disagreement between two
people who are committed to the end of
time to each other looks like clean up
your football stuff what football stuff
why are you yelling I'm not yelling and
you both love each other
and it's a matter of what pile goes
where not a matter of can I sleep in
this house tonight
and so she's going to be borrowing your
nervous system you're going to be
painting a picture for her of what
marriage could look like because she
does not have a good picture of what
marriage can look like
and it will be a hundred percent to be
expected that the first fight she gets
in with your son then she flies off the
handle because that's what she knows
that's what her body knows
and you're given another picture another
picture and if you set up a once a month
or once every two weeks breakfast
together not at home but in a different
air in a different geographic location
you'll sit down and you talk
and you listen way more than you talk
and just hear her story
and look her in the eye and let her know
that she's loved and okay man you're
talking about that is generational
change now
but for the time being I would run it
through and and by the way it's okay to
tell them this hey guys I had a picture
of what your courtship and marriage
would look like this wasn't it so we get
it we get a minute and I've told
countless 18 to 25 year olds hey you
just blew up your whole parent's world
with who you married or who you're in
love with that's great but they get a
minute too
and so I think it's fair to say we did
not have on our radar a weekend romantic
marriage
to someone you met on the internet that
was an hour picture and it wasn't our
picture to draw but we drew in anyway so
we get a minute we're figuring this out
too you get to say that all
but for the time being I would run that
through her daughter and I would I would
tell say the words I trust you
right now
my mom Instinct says I'm gonna reach out
to your parents and try to make a put an
olive branch on the table and connect
with them but I trust you you think
that's a good idea or not a good idea
and let's go from there let's go from
there
um
man they're really lucky to have you you
sound like a pretty awesome pretty
awesome Mom who loves her kids
love them a little too much but you love
your kids and that's amazing it's
awesome awesome that you called thank
you so much we'll be right back
hey what's up deloney here listen you
and me and everybody else on the planet
has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book building a non-anxious life
you'll learn the six daily choices that
you can make to get rid of your anxious
feelings and be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you so you
can build a more peaceful non-anxious
life get your copy today at John
deloney.com store that's John
deloney.com store
all right we're back as we wrap up the
show I know this this episode is coming
out a little bit late but
this is homage to the great Jimmy
Buffett who passed right around the time
we're recording this show and uh
Kelly picked these lyrics and they go
like this
why don't we get just kidding son of a
son of a sailor
as the son of a son of a sailor I went
out on the sea for adventure expanding
their view of the captain and crew like
a man just released from indenture
Adventures his teeth fell out I guess as
a dreamer of dreams and a traveling man
I've chalked up many a mile read dozens
of books about heroes and Crooks and
I've learned much about from both of
their Styles son of a son of a son of a
sailor son of a gun load the last ton
one step ahead of the jailer
I'm having a cheeseburger in Paradise
today shout out JB
love you guys we'll see you soon
[Music]
foreign